[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so stanley
wells
ihr wisst ja dass ich käsekuchen liebe
käsekuchen allen formen der klassische
käsekuchen der nature.tec egal in was
reformen heute mache ich einen
käsekuchen einmal wie kamst du seist
einem herzhaften käse kuchen und zwar
habe ich dir jetzt hier mit einem
richtig einfachen teig der wirklich
super schnell zubereitet ist im innern
habe ich eine füllung und eben einer
quarkmasse da habe ich noch frische
kräuter mit drin wie schnittlauch und
petersilie
frühlingszwiebeln und grünen spargel und
im prinzip könnt ihr das ganze als
grundrezept nehmen und diesen käsekuchen
abwandeln wie ihr möchtet
ich werde jetzt gleich mal mit den
zutaten für den teig und dann geht es
gleich los
für den teig braucht 200 gramm
dinkelmehl 50 gramm parmesan 150 gramm
sahne einen teelöffel rapsöl und halben
teelöffel salz für den teig gebe ich
jetzt die zutaten in einer rührschüssel
den könnte jetzt entweder mit den händen
verkneten mit einem mixer oder mit der
küchenmaschine samenreife ich hab ganz
frisch heißt es werde ich jetzt hier
darauf ab die fans traum
[Musik]
ob amazon auch mit er bringt die würze
mit dem teig dann die saure sahne rapsöl
und salz mit dem salz ein bisschen
sparsam das heißt und vier teelöffel
bitten halber teelöffel irgendein
parmesankäse und jetzt werden die
zutaten können miteinander verbunden
[Musik]
heiko bollich es aus und zwar auf etwa
32 cm größe von 35 zentimeter
durchmesser und sie lege ich dann
nämlich hier in den boxring eingehen
habe ich bereits auf 26 cm eingestellt
ihr könnt es hier auch nur spielen der
tat vom nehmen mit hier geboren oder
eine springform ich empfehle immer
backformen mit gleicher dafür einfach
dann ein bisschen besser durch baken und
dafür nehme ich jetzt eben das gelockte
backblech und den tortenring
der teig ist auch komplett unkompliziert
also ich kann damit auch ohne mehl
aufrollen und der doch ein bisschen
flexibel und elastisch sprinterin so ein
bisschen in form ziehen da muss jetzt
nichts perfekt sein und pflege ich den
hier rein und sie dann einen etwa zwei
bis drei zentimeter hoch
[Musik]
für die füllung brauche ich 500 gramm
magerquark 200 milliliter sahne 50 gramm
saure sahne dreier etwas parmesan käse
dann im schweizer 50 gramm
hier habe ich jeweils einen bund
petersilie schnittlauch
frühlingszwiebeln 500 gramm grünen
spargel und etwas salz und verrat
nämlich zuerst einmal die flüchtigen
zutaten oder die herzigen quatsch so
flüssig nämlich den quark daher auch der
käsekuchen
deswegen habe ich ihn auch so genannte
dies war eine etwas reduzierte variante
wäre mit könnt ihr aufnehmen aber ich
finde ein bisschen cremig muss der
kuchen schon sein von daher nehme ich
jetzt hier auch das stadtbild an die
saure sahne und die 1 jetzt erst einmal
[Musik]
computer parmesan mit rein und den raab
ich immer gerne ganz frisch
[Musik]
ganz gewiss noch mit pfeffer gewürzt und
als getreten und so viel wie das so dass
es eben gut schmeckt also der parmesan
ist doch wirklich schon seit 40 lässt
ich fange man immer erst mal mit einer
prise salz an damit doch noch überlegen
der spargel kommt noch mit dazu zieht
wir damit den sand wächst daher noch
nicht so sehr
jetzt kann ich noch die ganzen kräuter
hacken und einfach zu finden die spiele
habe ich übrigens immer gerne auf und
die gebe ich dann so was du bei einer
suche mit dazu einfach so damit sie den
geschmack annimmt
[Musik]
und dann kommen die kräuter mit dazu die
käsemasse ständig die cd kurz zur seite
und kann mich jetzt um den spargel den
habe ich bereits gewaschen und den muss
man nicht schälen auch bei manchen muss
man hier und 6 und dritten runter
schälen und den rest schneide ich dann
einfach in 23 cm langes stück
[Musik]
und jetzt lasse ich den grünen spargel
noch zwei minuten
das heißt einfach in kochendes wasser
und rudi nach zwei minuten gleich wieder
raus
deckel drauf und kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die füllung auf
den vorbereiteten teig diese
[Musik]
do
den spargel habe ich jetzt kurz
abtropfen lassen und gebe ihnen jetzt so
heiß wie er ist direkt in die käsemasse
so kommt der jetzt in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 180 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa eine stunde und danach lasse
ich ihn ein bisschen abkühlen und
langsam werden probieren der käsekuchen
ist jetzt abgekühlt ihr könnt ihr das
ich auch heißen
aber ich finde ihn abgekühlt viel besser
[Musik]
lecker lecker sagen so hatte schreitet
nicht da zum probieren
das heißt ich muss mich jetzt sehr gut
dass mit ihm zum sieg sowie gebackener
kräuter frischkäse auf einem leckeren
kuchen zeit wirklich sehr gut
er wird sich um zu allem sei frisch und
es schmeckt eigentlich nicht so schwer
wie jetzt solche außenrum mit einem
möglichen teil der viel butter
das heißt der schmeckt immer mal ein
bisschen schwer aber dieser zeit mit
saurer sahne ist sehr locker und leicht
und ich würde die sende käsekuchen dem
herzhaften auf jeden fall wieder zu
bereiten sagt auch mal in einer anderen
variation und weiß jetzt auch lust
brauch bekommen habt dann schaut auf
berlin - blog.de dass wir das konzept
noch mal ganz genau und ich wünsche euch
jetzt schon mal ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
singen und ich esse 2
[Musik]
die stiele habe ich übrigens immer gern
die fräs ein und wenn ich meine suppe zu
kochen gebe ich sie einfach mit dazu
geben geschmack ab und straßen wiens
meine gießkanne weg klingt farbe
gießkanne